[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
who tell me that you weren't singing
along to that band members Ali Campbell
and Astro are joining us now gentlemen
how lovely to see you
goodness me you were part of my youth
and Ally to you first of all and tell me
how you got inspired to get involved
well the guy who drives me around most
of the time Jed phoned my wife Julie to
say that Bill Withers had passed on I
was a great Bill Withers fan always have
been
and it was her idea really just to do a
version of lean on me you know because
it's it's so apt for that for our times
and for what we're going through you
know and so that's what we did we made
it in five days over the telephone and
got it mastered down in London propolis
and we released it a couple of weeks ago
but now we're releasing the video that
goes with it would like to say thanks to
all the people who were who came along
and made the video there's a lot of
great faces in there that's what
happened he rang you and said come on
mate yeah basically just as a it's got
an idea to do build with his song and as
he says erm we all love build weavers
and it was a shame to hear that he'd
passed away a couple of months ago and
so it just seemed like the perfect
choice the song does encapsulate
everything that the donations go through
in this present moment so you know it's
a perfect choice and there's only
Thursday night was great to have so many
people from the NHS and famous both
their faces taking the time to be part
of the video you know we wanted to show
her appreciation and to help raise more
money but they may chess together
charities so thank you to everybody who
got involved as
who else is in it you say famous faces
Astro people like circuit Richards I
haven't gone through all the footage
from Magnus put you on the spot ally the
NHS has got a special place in your
heart hasn't it that's why I wanted to
ask you that question well yeah I mean
when I was a seventeen-year-old kid I
was in I was put in hospital I was their
victim of a gas attack and I was in
hospital for a month in Birmingham with
what used to be the Birmingham my
hospital um and I decided then that
nurses were heroes you know and we've
supported the little help from your
friend thing a couple of years ago in
that so basically we've always supported
our national health system yeah Astro um
just just looking through a list of ub40
songs as I'm chatting to you I mean
goodness its immediately taking me back
to my youth what was your favorite don't
say red red wine because that's an easy
hit well it's not my favorite actually
well my favorite songs of all time that
we'd record is is the song called don't
break my heart
yeah and also when you smile yeah that
was 1985 something like that something
like that yeah Lee for me it was cherry
oh baby what about for you for me yep
wait you turn Astro is Ally's turn sorry
well Jerry Oh baby was just one of those
covers I mean we've made thirty albums
only four of those albums have been
cover albums called project called labor
of love and and sherry oh baby light red
red wine and many rivers to cross so
there were the songs that got us
involved